citizens of the reject Nation it is John
it is Tara Erickson said my full name
that's right people only say my full
name welcome to the club and if you're
mad about that you're going to be even
matter when you discover that you're
gonna like this when we're mad because
today we're checking out 2003's Hulk
Ah that's right not Mark Ruffalo not
Edward Norton not Lou Ferrigno But Eric
the binna checking out Ong Lee's film
haven't seen a lick of this but I
remember it it being a hotly debated
film when it first came out so hey don't
forget to smash that like Hulk out on
the subscription button and when you do
right now
oh and that way we won't be mad at all
because you'll be here with us and we'll
all be together but anyway guys check
out Tara Erickson on the social medias
check out La eats and drinks as well get
some food advice if you're stopping by
La and speaking of beloved comic book
characters if you happen to be in San
Diego this coming weekend sdcc Greg Coy
and I will be there for a panel on
Saturday one o'clock in the library come
join us we'll be very mad if you don't
come join us and finally people if you
want to get the full experience of Hulk
alongside us see everything that doesn't
make these reaction highlights come on
over to patreon.com the real rejects we
got a ton of other movies and shows over
there it's a lot of fun and without
further Ado Tara I'm ready you're ready
[Music]
oh
old school looks vaguely like the
Goosebumps slime almost
I do I do miss these intros whoa that
was really relaxing until it wasn't yeah
I missed these intros where it's like
ooh microscopic science thematic you
know yeah representation of what's to
come bioluminescence rapid response
[Music]
you trying to recreate humans or live
forever I can make super immune systems
by strengthening the human cellular
response manner I know where you're
going but manipulating the immune system
is dangerous and stupid dangerous and
stupid is what we're all about
no human subjects he said no humans
subjects man
this guy is trying to be a hero
I'm gonna have a baby
or no what's her name Jesus I don't know
her name
[Applause]
you got some little regenerative
abilities passed on to you up
it's been passed on
okay
interesting transitions
[Music]
oh okay a purple and green jeans Rose
your hurts
oh Bruce strange I didn't make a peep
he's like that he's just so
bottled up
holding it all in the samples we found
in your lab they were human blood you've
ignored protocol you had no right
snooping around in my lab it's
government business and you're off the
project
oh
man
don't fly off into a rage dude blow it
all up
failsafe has been initiated
I love this oh
David what's going on David Banner who's
there Bruce stay here what
[Music]
what's going on the killer in there oh
is it him
oh oh hello sir baby face Banner yeah
man
good morning Stanley and Lou Ferrigno
perfect can I just ask are you wearing
the helmet while she dumped you see it
protects my very important Brain Harper
always wears
hey oh girl hey review board we have to
make a presentation on Tuesday that's
working together after being so close if
I could be warm whatever you know
your boyfriend again
I don't know why but like she hasn't
aged like how she looks right now is how
she looks in the new Top Gun movie she
like looks the same they're actually
gonna figure out you know the serums
they used to keep her that way in this
movie give me some of that serum girl
and a man's fully dispersed
let's hit Freddie with the camera
radiation gamma radiation
imbalanced nanomed activity oh yeah that
doesn't look good he's bubbling over oh
my God is he gonna explode oh my God
that looked very painful how'd you like
to come work for Atheon get paid 10
times as much as you are now
and on a piece of patents
those patent rights two words
that's not a no
I would have Benny
Benny's dead
I'm the new guy uh
sound good sounds ominous
I know that voice
oh remember good old Kodak print out
pictures
wow that is a show whoa okay Harry
Potter
she's gonna leave the kid there she's
fine she's a military brat she can take
care of herself
whoa damn
that was the lab explosion looked like
[Music]
whoa what I just want to say that little
girl was very believable yeah I was like
how they get her to cry like that that's
what I think in every Steven Spielberg
film and now
sense something about you
okay this is like is he this is like a
bad dream okay
good old nightmare
is it that dog
you followed him home oh oh my it is
plus a creepy janitor
oh
my God like I know that voice anywhere
oh my God I wonder if he was like
drinking when he was filming this you
and I have never had the chance to get
to know each other properly well it's
because I don't want to get to know you
properly or improper
probably or biblically or otherwise here
forth and into eternity I just wanted to
say don't worry about him
I'll handle it
oh
With Your Love
you walked right past the hazmat suits
oh God drama
whoa whoa whoa whoa this is nope get out
of there
oh geez what in the actual I can't stop
it
oh no oh no get out
get out yeah get out get out of there
what are you doing
oh [__]
oh boy
never better oh
okay still get nightmares though bro
yeah still dreaming about Critters
on the other side
you're wondering why you're still alive
you're thinking there's something inside
inexplicable like a snowflake I can help
you understand
forgive me I'm sure I have nothing to
forgive you for you don't know that yet
dig a Little Deeper you may not want to
believe it but I can see it
in your eyes
so much like your mother s
Miss Ross again there's something you
need to know about our Bruce something
Troublesome let me protect you from her
this is intense
huh
yes all right
getting to work Jerry riggin
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
doodle gamma radiation experimentation
in my spare time it's cringe where you
work with
you know who he really is oh I think I
was hoping that maybe this time you just
honestly wanted to see me again
oh no
oh
I think I screwed up my father it's it's
like he suspects you something I don't
know him oh I just think that they're
planning something with the lap
call me okay oh here comes the Beast
yeah I thought her voice would calm him
down but not that news
what are we doing Jenners
yeah you gotta call your dad
yeah yeah yeah yeah here we go
let's do this whoa
all right yes yeah yes oh no whoa oh God
all your research yeah this is like Go
destroy outside of the the lamp
all right that is uh yep that's that's
an impressive amount of Destruction wow
sensory overload don't know if you're
gonna be happy about this after
oh no oh no Atlas Hulk oh
damn yep
solid looking effects in this movie so
far yeah like I was like how did they
put him with the real environment and
make it like it looks good
[Music]
a lot of complex feelings right now yeah
oh damn
whoa
okay you have my word I'll make sure
he's cared for for the next few days at
least
you're going to stay away from here and
no Continental services will be extended
every Banner the Continental Hotel is
closed
my father's with the military
he seems to think he's involved in some
kind of threat to National Security
the world will not tolerate his
existence will they but you
know
there's nothing I can do for him he's
made it clear he wants nothing to do
with me I have some work to do and I
have my scarf to get I'm the guy who had
your father tossed away and why are you
asking me I don't remember don't play
with me
four years old when you saw it oh yeah
when Sam Elliott comes at you cough it
up what
I mean people repressed strong depressed
memories
ever
come within a thousand yards of my
daughter again I'll put you away for the
rest of your natural life oh yeah all
right now sign this restraining order
thank you
yeah like what is he gonna use that for
make your dog's tracker you're gonna
pull some DNA oh there we go there we go
come get her I don't have nothing
standing in your way
what oh
those Shadows on the wall look dope
hello
Bruce so they think they can just throw
you away as they did me
poor guy an alteration genetic I'll
remove it and I'll kill it before it
does any real harm I don't think so I
don't know and as for Betty I'm sending
her surprise visit from some four-legged
friends of mine last year I've managed
the culture some of your very own DNA
Bruce oh no oh boy oh my God they're
Hulk dogs what about my DNA
sweet
s
there we go you're crazy
not in front of the government yeah
I wouldn't push him something tells me
he wanted much of it making stupid
threats to anyone
dude good luck
oh am I
say it
[Music]
oh damn oh cool
wow nice stunt
s oh
locked off
[Music]
wow awesome damn
whoa
whoa oh my goodness not the socks no how
he never tears through his pants he'll
never know
he's hiding in there
oh
yes
no
Hulk Hulk
staring
oh geez wow
whoa all right is this a comic book
thing oh my God
[Music]
like Terror dogs yikes
Ghostbusters [__]
get out of here poodle that damn poodle
oh
yes
I think so
holy tamale
whoa whoa whoa
oh bye bye tree
oh my God I would have reversed
whoa
man these things are Relentless oh
goodness oh
my gosh that looked insane yeah
oh God okay
oh pants finally came off all right all
right pee pants yep it must be the gamma
exposure but we've never seen any effect
like this
the game I just Unleashed what was
already there at least what
Bruce Banner is there anything from when
you were changed
it was like a dream
about what
murders
God when they hired her they were like
we're gonna need you to cry and like
every every scene yeah she's teared up
in every single scene like I'm like okay
girl we just
emotional damn can manifest physically
serious trauma buried memories sir when
it comes over me
and I totally lose control
I like it
yeah you do
what the damn it
I'm gonna take you someplace hey
Bruce huh
nice
[Music]
ah yep some place safe
thank you
oh
those good old fried memories I guess if
you want to dig those memories up it's a
good place to be
cool
wow wow
wow the deepest underground base why is
he such a threat to you because I know
where he comes from he says he doesn't
know his father but he's working in the
same exact God field his father did
I know the government thinks they have a
weapon on their hands otherwise he'd be
dead by now
God all they want in the meanwhile just
let me try to help him nobody knows him
better than I do come on dad what did
David Banner do to him
okay I mean too like if you're gonna use
it for a potential weapon you're going
to want a good under a little bug
control do a little bit of research you
know what I'm saying I love my research
so what are we gonna do we're gonna try
this on ourselves of course we are it's
gonna go well it's gonna go it's gonna
be great
oh okay
oh yeah
oh oh
what what's going on there what
is that
oh the starfish
up
oh is he gonna become the Abomination
[Music]
whoa oh he's like uh yeah camouflaging
it oh interesting anything you touch you
become that's gonna be tough because
it's metal oh
wow interesting
that's a cool visual yeah that's a very
cool visual
I'm gonna have to ask you to
put your hands up pal okay nice and easy
well
do you really believe that I am separate
from you
interesting it's almost like he's like
gorilla glow where am I
of your home
I don't know if that's what I would call
it yeah that doesn't look like a like a
home to me oh but they can take walks in
the desolate Wasteland yeah and go to
that melted down ice cream shop this is
my old house isn't it
yeah Mama was standing right out there
let's go
to remember you're gonna have to go in
that room the room where it happened
there we go is starting to unlock it are
you afraid we'll see
there's nothing
it's empty
nah bro that wasn't the point of this
exercise you didn't see it but a ton of
bad memories just came tumbling out of
that doorway when you opened it NSA has
decided to turn over study of the uh the
threat
to Atheon
[Applause]
I thought she'd put up a little bit more
of a fight these idiots man haven't they
ever seen a werewolf movie
gotta have the one girl calms him down
otherwise all hell's gonna break loose
oh hello there you got roughed up bro
and I can carve off a piece of the real
you
analyze it patented make a fortune
this is a very bad idea you turn green
and all these guys come in and kill you
and I perform the autopsy maybe my
actually go too far break your neck or
maybe he just kills you and everyone
else there yeah you know consciously
oh
oh we're going deep all right let's jump
start those brain waves
[Music]
that gives me like claustrophobia Vibes
yeah I did miss Ross welcome back you
don't have to worry I'm not angry with
you
but you wouldn't like it if I was angry
if you could persuade your father that
if I turn myself in now peacefully that
he would let me see my son
well this is a good idea you should
blame yourself for what you've done to
your son and what have I done to my son
well
you know buddy oh you've given Bruce is
fear
and distance yeah
fear of life and emotional scars I could
tell from the moment she conceived that
it wasn't the son I had given her a
monster maybe what but they took away my
chance to cure him your father threw me
out
I remember that day so what
I knew I was doing a father's work
fulfilling father's Mercy
oh my he's gonna kill Bruce and kill the
mom instead
it was as if ah she and the knife
hey yeah that's one way to put it that
is a hell of a repressed memory yeah yep
and transformed
into nothing more
Than A Memory
he's oh no
that's some sad [__] sir negative on
drill penetration damn it drilling
harder give me pull our pants come on
Holmen come on
please
now when he be hulking
let's get it
no I can't do anything with goo come on
[Music]
didn't look like there was enough
additional space to account for the
water displacement
[Music]
I feel like he could bypass that oh
maybe not she says it out you know send
in our containment team non-lethals only
I repeat non-lethals only I must have a
sample of him a minute ago you're like
I'm gonna kill you in here yeah say
anything
under control General I'll let you know
if we need you
immediately I want a full court
evacuation holy tamale this might give
you a bit of a sting here Bruce
ah in the actual F why does it have to
be there
[Music]
big boy
it's terrific
[Music]
nice
I mean gotta observe this have we
learned anything
they're clearly bouncing off this dude
yeah come on now get out while you can
notice the severe lack of bullet wounds
blood yeah
get it
oh that looks awesome Ultimate Frisbee
show him the way out
we'll fight him outside I guess I okay
whoa nice okay nice
no
[Music]
no okay
wow what
oh
what the whoa wow dude
cool wow that's awesome all about
sensory some of this stuff is it's like
almost tactile in a very different way
yeah like you can feel it with the
sounds and the the way that it's shot I
feel like well it's like no yeah and
they give you like enough air in some of
these moments to like just kind of yeah
hahaha
[Music]
yeah I'd be like burp let's turn around
now yeah
[Music]
thank you
shake them down that's great
yeah Shield
geez
smash
tell you right now Hulk makes me want to
go to a rage room yeah right rage it out
both to a rage room and also on a road
trip through the country a trampoline
there you go trampoline park
hmm
yes just shoot him more the battle must
begin
you gotta know not to get that close at
very least
what has a close call
angle one clear
[Music]
so I'm loving these locations geez I'm
like part of me is like Zach's packed
and exciting but also how beautiful
is he hold oh he is that's awesome let
it go at just the right time
oh nice me at this point I feel like
they should have learned not to hit him
physically let's try to emotionally hurt
him yes that might work let's ridicule
him
turn it into a parking lot
oh
this is National Treasure
I mean you really he's broken through
buildings and through ceilings y'all you
think that's really gonna do it this is
what we know how to do
this isn't where I parked my car he's
headed your way probably right for you
I'm already here
father and now
it's all good news no it's not
dad's got some some of his sleeve and by
something up his sleeve I mean his arm
has literally become the texture and
fabric of the sleeve
okay
we're a clear Target fire at will it's a
cool detail with the maps on his knees
[Music]
Wowie
I have so many mere misses
okay
oh smart nice take him on a ride to the
top of the world let's see what the thin
air will do for him
okay that's a decent plan
yeah what will it do oh yeah just break
the glass and get in the plane yeah
out of my envelope whoa
yeah in their Legend I can't maintain
Hulk had it
says before you
maybe not oh that's cool
laughs
wow uh oh
another nightmare
huh
uh
nice
whoa okay puny humans whoa speaks
[Music]
you gotta work with the puny human man
in the water
oh boy I feel like she has cast for so
many of these types of roles like she's
the long-suffering companion to the guy
who's going through some extraordinary
[__] yep
just Beauty killed the Beast
I mean
I feel like they might have figured that
out
give him a chance to calm down it seems
so simple
aircraft
oh my God
all right here comes Hulk I was about to
ask what is this doing to the utilities
and the infrastructure Wowie
okay awesome stunt there God High School
score
parachute out of there go to him yeah
[Music]
oh
huh full
transformation yeah oh weird weird oh
you found me oh
you aren't that hard to find
[Laughter]
yes I was
buried in here under all these repressed
memories they were pretty strong but not
stronger than our love love is the true
radiation it unlocks the potential
meantime if he does anything but sit
there in that chair I'm gonna turn on
the juice he'll be incinerated
immediately okay I mean calm down she's
right she's right here she solved a lot
of your problems shouldn't you just be
like thank you the Nuance is staring you
in the face guys I should have killed
you
I should have killed you
I wish you had
I saw her last night she reached down
kissed my cheek
I can almost remember a smell
my mother
I don't even know her name
sorry I said
let it out maybe once you were my father
but you're not now and you never will be
I didn't come here to see you
to see my son
the one inside of you you can think what
you like I don't care just go
am I making you angry my cells can
transform too but unlike you they're
unstable I need strength ugh oh okay
damn it man now you must give it back to
me
stop stop what
wow
I'll go
you just watch me go hit it
oh
whoa
oh boy
holy junk what what what going on Doctor
Manhattan right now okay
hit it again we can't sir there's no
power some kind of counter
electromagnetic field
what you've done it now oh cause he can
absorb all the electricity oh sure the
power
what whoa okay whoa
I am Holy junk what are they like
fighting through the clouds what is
ah
[Music]
oh
wow yes yikes that looks scary oh no
it's like the rock monster from Galaxy
Quest
are there any elements off limits
oh boy okay you can't take water form
that's right keep fighting the more you
fight the more of you I take
so you have to learn to control it so he
don't get it kid start meditating Hulk
Struggle No More
and give me all of your power of course
take it
take it off oh
damn yes
yes wow
[Music]
whoa oh my gosh she's turning into a
twister
[Music]
oh
it's too much whoa like oh wow I mean
you asked for it man damn
[Music]
oh it's like a nuclear like oh wow
nuclear
trauma memory cloud
oh
okay
well we both know that Bruce couldn't
survived that blast
but if by some chance he did survive
you should try to contact you you'll try
to get in touch you tell me wouldn't you
no no I wouldn't you know as well as I
do I wouldn't have to phones are bad my
computer's tapped I'm under surveillance
what are you talking about no you're not
if you were alive I'm the last person I
would want him to come to I am so sorry
I know you are
see like in the room with her right now
it's Gotta Be there's got to be some
kind of yeah secret someplace the bugs
can't
tapadre medicine okay
uh cheapers no okay rude what's going on
here
yeah buddy nice oh yeah yeah oh here we
go
oh man
[Music]
and of course
Forest looks like a fungus Fade to Green
perfect
love it well done that was good times I
did enjoy that you know this movie gets
a very weird rap I feel I feel like
there are a lot of differing opinions
about it but uh I had a good time I had
a good time I did think like in the
beginning it was a little slow like I
wanted finally when he was kind of
starting to Hulk out I got like excited
when the music started to kick in you're
like all right let's get to it they did
take their time and the last shots would
which I did like like taking time with
the character and his life and what came
before I enjoyed yeah
um
and but yeah there was there was some
moments where I was like we could cut
into these a little bit faster to give
us like quicker juice but I was all
right with the with the pacing overall
as it is Once from Finish to end I was
like all right I get it this is a style
I like it I I liked the Transitions and
the editing a lot
um and Jennifer Connelly single tear man
Bravo yes she really does hold it down
for this kind of role in particular but
I was happy to have her here like I I
enjoyed Eric Bana and uh Jennifer
Connelly quite a bit I mean you know
they they have a little bit of there
could be a little bit more warmth to
their chemistry but I feel like it makes
sense as to who especially Bruce is and
all this sort of like repressed stuff
and everything but yeah I would agree
like it definitely moves and I've heard
people describe I think Greg has
described this before as like it's much
more of like a comic book Drama than it
is like a super zero action flick yeah
and I could definitely see this not
exactly being what people want ideally
want it out of a a big Hulk movie like
this but I I find it really fun to peer
back into you know the earlier phases of
this kind of Cinema because this is I
mean you know this is kind of
not this form of movie but just the
philosophy is I feel like what we're
sort of trying to return to which is
like the Zhang Lee clearly he had a
vision for this or at least it seems
like he was really able to you know
direct this movie and put his earmarks
on it and so like I appreciated that it
allowed the scenes to breathe and I
appreciated yeah the comic book editing
and stuff like that like all the actors
showed up like even though the Third
I guess you'd call that like a third
actor third act fourth act like when he
when he finally uh meets when uh David
Banner father Banner comes back to see
him and then absorbs all the energy and
then you get this like that bit felt a
little tacked on just because it's like
oh yeah I guess we should have him go up
against like a super powered villain of
some kind with like true ill intent not
just the military who is sort of uh you
know uh bullishly you know sort of
firing at him all over the place like
even though they are antagonistic to
Hulk because we understand Hulk you're
like I get it they're trying to you know
protect a their interest but also B
people from getting wantonly Massacre
taking care of them right
um so yeah but Dad went at him
emotionally that's true you see what I
was saying they were physically dad was
like I'm gonna get in here yeah and I'm
like as much as this movie could
certainly be tighter or shorter or more
again of like a an action movie in its
focus I I you know by the end you get
there and you're like yeah like
everything got its opportunity to uh
just grow you know the the story of you
know Bruce's trauma and what he had to
deal with as a child that stuff being
repressed uh coming back into uh contact
with his father and sort of having his
life turned upside down by that and then
ultimately at the end his dad coming
back to finish the research all that
stuff just felt like it it unfolded
pretty naturally uh and you know
everything with Betty Ross and uh and
her father you know yeah
um I don't know yeah it's like
everything felt like it was given the
amount of breathing room it needed
nothing felt like it was like overly
choppy and yeah sometimes you are like
maybe we could speed this up a little
bit but I did like that it was graceful
and it didn't feel again yeah like it
was cut up in a blender or something or
like there were a bunch of interests
they had to get to or something like it
felt like its own own movie and I like
that yeah and I felt like that like even
with the time they had I'm like you
could have maybe without all the
montages of like environment and
helicopters and shooting him a bunch in
it not working I'm like oh would have
been cool to see a little bit more of
him and Betty relationship Foundation
just at the top so that sure we felt a
little bit more like when he looks at
her at the end all they needed was like
her in the helicopter looking at him and
they can tell that like oh that works oh
all right oh all right just like but I
guess put your weapons down
okay go see him
um I I it could maybe hit a little bit
harder for us of feeling that connection
yeah possibly if if we had a little bit
more of their relationship at the top
but
um still overall I was like yeah the I
mean Hulk dogging it he had to take care
of them and then save her and I was like
that was cool like uh that felt like a
thing out of a comment yes book movie
that felt like a bit of a different kind
of like most things that happened even
the finale fight with his dad felt like
pretty well attuned to what this is but
the the Hulk dogs did feel kind of if
that was very like Fantastical comic
bookie in a different way like this felt
like largely like a drama that was using
some comic book visuals and language to
kind of you know embellish itself and to
kind of split the difference but that
really felt like a comic book thing yeah
and Nick Nolte at the end when he got
all Nick Nolte yeah when he gives that
speech I was like oh he's off his rocker
now let's do it Nick and he went all the
way he went all the way like I gotta I
gotta you know I I joke about Nick Nolte
sometimes but I mean he is a good actor
and he shows up like when he shows up he
shows up that's the thing is I feel like
you could have easily not shown up to
this movie in so many of the different
roles and I thought everybody everybody
did and I would be curious to know what
people think of Eric Bana as Bruce
Banner because obviously I'm not the
expert on like what is the most Comics
accurate or whatever
um but I liked his presence yeah like it
would have been nicer to see a little
bit of their love and their romance just
to drive that home into feel yeah that
kind of warmth that they're fighting to
get back to and maybe drive home the
idea that like oh like you know it
logically makes sense that she would be
the thing to calm him down but like if
you had that little extra oomph so that
you could really feel that I think that
would have been kind of neat it also
would have made
um is it the other guy like more of a
villain her ex-boyfriend like if if
they're Josh the Josh Lucas guy yeah
yeah yeah the Josh Lucas guy like if if
her and Eric Bana were like you know a
solid and then what does not swings in
and then it would have made him a little
bit more of a villain yeah totally a
little bit God and that too like that I
mean he is of the character like I
really like that they gave Ross as much
as he is an antagonist through a lot of
this and especially in his younger form
he is very sort of standoffish I did
like the way they humanized him whereas
I do feel like Talbot the Josh Lucas
character is like the most of all the
human villains he is the most sort of
like he's like Justin Hammer but but
like shittier yeah he's yeah he's uh
he's just a complete opportunist with no
s common sense for like the situation in
front of him he's just trying to get to
that bottom line
um but you know I feel like it's funny
because Josh Lucas I feel like gets put
into that role a lot too where he's like
you know some kind of either rival in a
similar lane or just somebody who's
there to a kind of swoop in and and you
know get in on on you know a potential
relationship with the girl the
protagonist is in love with but also
he's just kind of like a business douche
like what's that movie with Julia
Roberts he's exactly that where she's
the money and the well and it's bad
water and he's there oh yeah come on
guys
yeah Aaron Brockovich that movie he's in
that and he plays what he's saying and
it was carabono from stranger things who
was his mom it was yes
okay yeah yeah this is this is
interesting this is fun I liked I liked
a lot of the settings and stuff like
that and I loved that they it's funny we
see a lot of desert battles now the
flash recently just had one and and I
feel like often times nowadays people
are like ah man these drab fight scenes
just out in some kind of desolate you
know desert tan backdrop and I really
loved it's like that felt like the
climactic action scene when you know
he's escaping the base and all the
militaries coming after him and stuff
like that and he's like traversing the
country
yeah but I thought that stuff was
beautiful like they really used
locations nicely and I thought they also
shot their effects really well because
for 2003 I think this looks really good
in a lot of respects like yeah some of
the full sunlight shots you're like of
course it's CG but like so much of this
stuff they shot in partial Shadow and
they still managed to put in little
flourishes like the sprinkler coming
down in that one scene that like helped
to sell it Beyond just like oh smart
you're not having to use as much detail
um but yeah like showing him on screens
and things like that or from afar and
just the way they handled the physics of
the Hulk uh yeah just like really nicely
I thought drawn and so again like
meeting this halfway as a superhero
drama I was like
pretty pretty interesting pretty decent
like there's a lot of uh interesting and
quality work that went into this and I
think yeah especially with how far the
effects the CG has come on a character
like alcohol 2003 though I was like wow
he's like moving around that environment
things aren't moving and that thing
looks real and I know he's not but it
like the way that they melded the
environment together for like old school
CG I was like yeah good job yes yeah
they did a really nice job with that and
uh
yeah I mean overall
overall I liked it it was it was felt
like a little long for me I was like oh
but overall I like I like the movie yeah
and I and I also appreciated that there
was like again I'm not the biggest Hulk
expert necessarily but I did enjoy uh
having this additional element with the
prologue and everything and his father
experimenting on himself you know it's
not just the gamma radiation that
unlocks the Hulk it's all this other
genetic material that has been
experimented with and then passed along
to Bruce
thought that stuff was was nicely done
and even the thing with the repressed
memories and like the inherited trauma
and stuff like that it just like it felt
like uh like Angeli and Company really
thought about this and uh and and even
if again it's not like the exact
blueprint of like your ideal superhero
joint I think they still like managed to
help pave the road in a really nice way
and there are aspects of this I would
love to see you know come back in some
way also just a quick final thought uh
justice for Daniel Day Kim is in this
movie yeah and he's in like two scenes
and he's just like kind of he's just
like an assistant too he's like here's
the file sir yeah he's just an assistant
to Thunderbolt Ross when he's got comic
book movie cred as well from uh uh
Hellboy and some other things so I don't
know this is a fun little little deep
but uh any any other uh
points or Deets you want to go over
before we hit the road just don't
repress those bad memories I mean like
keep them down but then like maybe let
him out so then they're they're out you
know so you're not like hurting like he
was for a long time you know be honest
with yourself yeah therapy is a great
the therapy you know yes it is that's a
that's a bar better help should contact
you and and license that quote
I was in a better help commercial I
thought that's where John was going that
there you go I was in a parachute you
guys wouldn't even be able to recognize
me I think I dropped it on my YouTube
channel when I was in it two years ago
you can do the research if those brand
dollars Tara Eric hey baby well guys I
hope you're not angry that we checked
this movie out and if you are leave a
comment below expressing your anger
that's a better way to do it than going
out and destroying things leave a like
on the video let us know what else you'd
like us to check out and uh hey before
we hit the road let's do a page
Daniel gallacher you know where this is
going buddy I know you you're easy he
lives in Scotland he's a pharmacist
among other things or he works you know
at a pharmacy and so I feel like if
anybody at our patreon is in the prime
position to do some off the Record
experimentation maybe enhance his
physiology and maybe unlock some
repressed memories in the process it's
Daniel gallacher all right and I cannot
wait for the potential of what you might
turn into who you might Hulk out as you
know Mercy's gotta makes up the drugs
though because he's got he's got to do
the pharmacy the drugs and then and all
his different genes yeah and then he can
Hulk out oh yeah but no no testing on
animals yeah
all good experiments are tested on
yourself that's what I've learned from
every movie
that's true and that's what what better
way to go than doing what you love Yeah
and uh we love you we love that you're
pledged to the patreon so no matter what
you turn into just make sure you're in
the same way that uh that uh Bruce
Banner left his wallet at the lab that
first time he hoped out leave yours at
the patreon before you go out into the
world and do whatever hulking you're
gonna do so uh hey buddy we love you
stay pledged and we'll catch you next
month let's smash bye
[Music]